foreign
I've pretty much dug a hole for myself
with so much debt which I barely ate
which I'm barely able to keep up on the
payments I went over my limits on
several credit cards and have a few
loans and I'm very close to hitting
ninety thousand dollars in debts
I want to know if it's okay to
temporarily stop paying for some of the
big payments and focus on the smaller
payments first and then focus on the
bigger payments I'm just unable to make
all the payments and be able to pay for
other necessary things like rent utility
and transportation
for the past few months the past couple
of months I've actively tried to sell
more of my belongings which I really
don't need I've also taken on a couple
of weekend jobs but I'm still struggling
to keep up please advise on my best
option to getting back on track before I
try the baby steps man this is it's a
mess I'm so grateful for this question
um Sal because you know on this show
John we yell out folks all the time look
at how you're spending your money you're
not doing it right all this stuff but
this is this is real deal right here
because this is somebody who they're
doing the best they can they made some
mistakes and you know they're just
trying to make ends meet so let's let's
be real honest there does come a moment
when you've dug yourselves quite a hole
and you can work two or three jobs and
any it ain't you're making a dent in
that hole man you're preaching to the
choir it just is right and so it's easy
for us to be like you just need to get
out there and get another job and a
third job sometimes you dug yourself a
hole and it's a mess look I re when I
when you read Sal's question I relate
directly to that and I hope that Sal and
anybody else listening knows man back in
gosh Sam what was it back in 2012 2011.
um we were in exactly cell situation so
much debt so many payments we literally
couldn't pay them all we had to stop
with some of them and just
tell the others to take a hike be like
hey you're just gonna have to call my
phone and that's what I you know I refer
to that I know people call Baby Step
Zero different things for us baby Step
Zero was simply quit creating more debt
like if you can just stop stop like not
drown and not make the water any deeper
that is successful and that was uh gosh
almost two years of the first part of
our journey was just trying to get
enough footing to where we could just
pay all of our bills
um so I understand what that means and
when you're in that situation you've got
to focus on that four walls you've got
to focus on hey I gotta keep the rent
going like I can't default on my rent I
can't get evicted that's number one You
Gotta Eat You Gotta make sure that
there's food coming in you're eating you
got to keep the lights on utilities
that's next and you got to get
Transportation it doesn't have to be
expensive Transportation I don't care if
you're taking the bus you got to make
sure there's money for gas bus ticket
Uber right whatever it is that you need
to do to get by and if you're able to do
that you can breathe it night and
can we just
this isn't to celebrate us this is just
to to just provide a picture of what
this looks like I have rented an
upstairs bedroom in my friend's mom's
house before I have driven a 3500 truck
to my Dina student's job come on I have
you know I'm saying like I've given my
wife's old used Corolla that she sold
and I bought back at a less you know
what I mean yeah like you just I know
you guys I mean you and Sam jeez man
y'all went through it right look I
remember on a Friday having no money in
the account I would I would go to the
grocery store because we needed food I'd
write a bad check on a Friday knowing
that check can't clear on Saturday
Sunday that gave me two days it gave Sam
and I two days I'd teach lessons I'd do
anything I could to get money in the
account before Monday so it wouldn't
overdraw right sometimes we did it
sometimes we didn't eat today right
Gotta Eat You Gotta Eat and it that was
it was like I knew to do that because
I'm like okay they can't they can't
charge this check over the weekend this
is my chance so I get it if you're out
there and you're struggling I see that
when I'm out here you're going on a rail
and yelling at folks I'm not talking to
you I know that you're scratching your
clawing you're doing whatever you need
to do to get by the folks I'm yelling at
is the people who can pay their bills
who are sitting on their hands while the
government is holding your student loans
off and you're waiting for that single
person to pay that bill for you you're
the one that needs to get off your butt
and do some work